para los agentes, y en este lado para los agentes, y adentro, un paseo.
¿Tú sabes mi corazón? Tengo mis hijos escondidos.
No sé a dónde ellos están, ellos no saben a dónde yo estoy, aquí ya está su papá, ya está todo, todos.
Mi hermano, mayor que yo, se escondieron con el señor Adel en un búnker.
No agarraron, yo no sabía.
Trepento, veo, y en este pasillo, está paseando ese director de sede en un bloque.
Hace un paseo, y él habló a mí, y no dijo nada.
Inmediatamente regresó, al frente del edificio de SES,
el jefe de exportación para las subidas, Nietzsche, como está en papel, como usted lo vio allá.
Señor Ademir, señor Ademir, y SES.
Trepento, veo yo, que él está regresando, con Nietzsche, con jefe, y me hace con el dedo así.
Me salgo, me agarro en mano, y me llevo al frente del edificio.
Estaba donde SES, con Santa María, y con SES, en Lambros, y ahí estoy allá.
¿Qué van a hacer conmigo? Yo no sé.
¿De qué se trata? No sé.
Yo no sé, que ya no estoy entre 15.000 personas o 12.000 que van a llevar al comatorium.
No sé qué está pasando.
¿Cómo era Nietzsche?
Nietzsche era el jefe de SES, que manejaba con todo mandato para la gente del comatorium.
¿Cómo era él físicamente?
Físicamente era, mire, más o menos tenía su altura.
Yo estoy viendo, mire, él, 1,75.
No corto barriga, no.
Sabes, como ellos, con Antonio Sassi, con su hija, Marcia, voy a decirlo hoy.
Él mandaba todo, con toda Santa María, el jefe de toda arena.
¿Joven, mayor?
Más o menos 45 años.
43 o 42, más o menos, esa edad.
Y ahí estoy allá.
Sacaron cuatro personas más.
Gente joven que trabajaba en este cerebelo.
De repente, veo yo que agarran a mi hermano.
La cuñada, con dos hijos, se está llevando también para allá.
Entonces, yo, engañó.
Abrió la puertica y puso el dedo, venga para acá, aquí estamos.
Y este, mire, era SES y Santa María.
Más bajo que SES.
No sabía de qué se trataba.
Entraron conmigo acá.
Yo, engañó.
¿Y su mamá dónde estaba?
La mamá de usted, ¿dónde estaba?
Estaba muerto. Murió en el año 40.
¿Cómo murió su mamá?
Cuando la vio la primera acción, quemados, llevaban los niños en sus coches,
para subirlos,
2500, que sacaban de así, y dijo yo no quiero vivir más.
No quiero vivir, no quiero vivir, no quiero vivir, y murió.
Y todavía tenía un gran SES, un gran honor,
que me estaban cuatro hermanos.
Uno hermano estaba ya en Venezuela.
Y se me cargaron con los hombros, mi mamá, al cementerio.
Toda ciudad andaba atrás.
Y ellos dijeron que esta señora hizo alguna gran cosa en el mundo,
que ella tiene suerte, que van a entrar en el cementerio.
Aparte, cuando empezó el crematorio,
y subieron, sacaron, tumbaron todos los monumentos,
hasta sacaron huesos del cementerio y llevaron para el crematorio.
¿Por qué?
Para liquidar todo, que no se quede huesos, no se quede, tampoco.
Liquidaron todos los monumentos y hicieron callos.
¿Y el de su mamá también?
Todos.
¿Eso fue en qué año?
En el año 41.
¿Y usted se despidió de su mamá?
¿Qué hablaba con ella para que cambiara de opinión?
Ya no hablaba, mire.
Era mujer muy inteligente,
y ya sabía qué iba a pasar.
Y ella dijo, en mi vida,
yo quiero lograr que Dios me ayude,
que no vean que me van a matar.
Yo quiero lograr que Dios me ayude,
que no vean que me van a matar mis hijos.
Esa era el único corazón, y así era.
Cuando ella vio, no pasó nada.
Déjeme terminar más importante.
Cuando yo estoy al frente del edificio de Sest,
y tengo a mi hermano y cuñado, dos hijos, tan pequeños,
estoy viendo, mire,
que dos resaltos me di, están llevando a mi señora.
Para adentro.
Imagínate, usted puede imaginar,
mi corazón, mi todo, como era.
¿Qué puede ser?
Ella a mí, no la vi.
Me dijeron, que tú, mozo, puedes mirar en un lado,
trechito, a donde llevamos, y llévala adentro,
y se paró al lado de su papá,
de sus hermanos, de todos los familiares, de todos, mire,
ya tengo a mi señora allá adentro.
Ese es el sábado.
Sábado a las dos,
se baja el rector,
dice Sr. Rice, tú estás salvado,
y dentro de una hora, ya va a llevar todo para el crematorio,
tú estás salvado.
Entonces yo digo, el polaco,
tú eres un ángel.
Ángeles tienen que cumplir con todas las leyes.
Dice, ¿qué ley?
Mire,
querido amigo, tú me salvaste,
y no me salvaste.
¿Qué pasó?
Ahorita me agarraron a mi señora, ahí estaba escondido,
saló por rayos de todo el mundo huyendo,
¿cuál polaco va a esconder un judío?
Queman la casa, queman vivos toda la gente,
no hay salvación.
Entonces dijeron, vaya de la casa.
Y ella no tenía ni idea de lo que estaba pasando.
Y ella no tenía otra alternativa,
salió y agarraron a ella.
¿Qué quiero?
Yo quiero, si usted puede,
traer a mi señora conmigo para acá.
Y le dicen a la mamá,
Dios, mi Dios,
eso no puede pasar,
eso es imposible,
Dios lo trae a su señora.
Te voy a repetir la palabra que dije antes.
Tú eres ángel, y no existe completo su trabajo,
yo voy a regresar,
vivir junto y morir junto.
El hombre se quedó ya.
Era de altura muy bajo.
Gentleman, gentleman, gentleman.
¡Oh!
Mi querido Dios,
ayúdame.
Habló con él mismo, y salió.
El edificio donde vivía,
era de tres pisos.
Primero piso Nietzsche,
otro SS, así siguió.
Se fue para allá.
Y dijo en alemán,
mi amigo,
mi conductor,
y mi seguidor,
Adam Reich,
Adam.
Y él,
y mi seguidor,
no podía ir.
Y luego pasó,
aquí pasó
una cosa
que agradó a su señora.
Y él dijo que no.
Dijo a su señora,
él,
regresa,
y yo, oyendo abajo, todo.
Piso como aquí, mire,
estoy allá, mire, y estoy oyendo todo.
Mi hermano, yo, mire,
gente fue a quitarme allá, mire, oyeron.